por quinto día consecutivo los aviones
de combate y los buques de guerra chinos
siguen en acción beijing decidió ampliar
su entrenamiento militar a lo largo de
taiwán con banderita taiwanés territorio
de china china lleva a cabo ejercicios
de militares normales en las aguas que
rodean su propio territorio es abierto
transparente y profesional los
departamentos chinos pertinentes también
han emitido anuncios de manera oportuna
esto está en línea con la ley nacional
el derecho internacional y la práctica
internacional
estas maniobras chinas que comenzaron
tras la visita en nancy pelosi a taiwán
debían terminar el domingo a pesar de la
amenaza todo avanza con normalidad en
las calles de taipei contrario a las
decisiones de las autoridades de la isla
que acaban de anunciar sus propios
ejercicios militares a partir del martes
los aviones y barcos chinos nunca han
entrado en nuestro espacio aéreo ni en
nuestras aguas territoriales nuestros
militares desplegaron aviones y barcos
para responder a las posiciones enemigas
sin embargo taipei dice que las
maniobras estaban previstas desde hace
mucho tiempo la isla democrática y
autónoma vive bajo la constante amenaza
de una invasión por parte de china
beijing considera a su vecino como parte
de su territorio y su objetivo es
recuperarla por la fuerza de ser
necesario